you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna say something controversial I'm
gonna say something controversial go on
then I enjoyed my trip in America this
time
we we everyone knows we like America we
like America we're just in there is for
America yeah so this time I was like I
guess I guess it was like the
first time in a while when I've where
I've been to America purely just for a
holiday no working no working no
collabing with YouTube YouTubers no kind
of like no way no convention to go to I
just went to America chilled out with
some friends and uh yeah went to Napa
Valley and oh that's why okay no no
actually actually at we we you know the
history has been solved
even before Napa Valley you know it's uh
we uh went to uh Lake Tahoe uh which is
kind of like near San Francisco I see so
many of these places in movies I just
assume that they're like you know I look
like Tahoe Lake Thomas have you been to
Lake Tahoe I've been to Lake Tahoe yeah
it's a Lake Tahoe it's a lake called
Tahoe yeah why is it always mentioned
what's so special about it I have no
idea it's just uh it's just a nice area
it's very I didn't understand what uh
you know America core is until I went to
a place like Lake Tahoe and I'm like oh
this is like American tourism just like
in a nutshell it's like just like a nice
Scenic Lake and then there's like a
little touristy town with little
Trinkets and souvenirs it's what
Japanese people envisioned the perfect
American holiday so yeah I feel yeah it
is the perfect American holiday and
going to Lake Tahoe after spending so
much time in Japan this is uh this is uh
This is Gonna it's gonna sound like a
joke but it's not I realized I kind of
uh kind of missed the freedom you get in
America he's been indoctrinated
what do you mean we lost a fellow
brother I don't know because like
sometimes you go on a holiday in Japan
you want to do like an activity or
something right and it's just like you
have to phone ahead make sure everyone
has the right equipment make sure
everything is booked out you go in the
at the right time zone you've missed
that time slot and then it was just nice
being in somewhere like Lake Tahoe and
just waking up and being like what do we
feel like doing today oh let's rent a
boat oh do we have to book out anything
so we didn't know if we haven't booked
out a book out a boat or something like
that so we went for lunch somewhere and
then we just saw that there was a boat
rental place like right next to the
lunch place we were going to and we were
just like let's just ask if we could you
know maybe book out a boat maybe today
or tomorrow uh so we go to the place and
they're just like yeah when do you need
a boat just uh and uh uniquely Japan
problems this is this is a very Japan
problem and and I was like you need a
licensed and they're like nope Judy had
a Time slow and they're like when do you
think you're gonna be back and we can uh
just get you uh did you if if you can't
drive a boat we can get you a captain no
worries uh that is like the mentality I
love that Japan does not have like the
[__] it mentality yeah it's just been
like yeah [__] it
[__] it I'm like uh can we like bring
like fishing rods or can we have like
other stuff on the boat and they're like
yeah you can uh you can do you know
water ski if you want you can do like uh
all these other activities huh I did not
water skiing that day because the the uh
the water was [__] freezing funnily
enough it was it was so pretty like
there were still places near Lake Tahoe
where you can go skiing and this was
like in June so I was like what is this
weather right now this is very confusing
but I did go uh the word [__] uh fly
fishing I went fly fishing okay for the
first time which I've been I I've
realized now I've done a lot of
different kinds of fishing and before
like two years ago I'd never fished in
my life I was like all fishing is kind
of the same right which
uh yeah all fishing the same you are
just you just put the rod in the water
wait for the light and then you just
reel it in I played in a fishing mini
games yeah I thought I thought all
fishing was basically the fishing mini
game in every video game you've ever
played uh and the first exhibition
experience was basically just that it
was basically you're on a lake you just
put out the line wait for the fish to
buy and the bite feels exactly like
it does in a video game if you feel the
vibration and then you just like start
you see that press a prompt you see the
press a prompt and then you just start
reeling it in and and then we had the
fishing trip with geeks plus and that
was like fishing easy mode yeah right
the last baby mode yeah we've briefly
talked about this but we've we're like
in a river and then they literally threw
the fish in this River for us to catch
they said this there is this many fish
here's the tutorial yeah I love how at
that time to everyone everyone saw that
yeah they didn't even make it subtle and
we all just kind of silently agree with
like let's just pretend we didn't see
that
that's like just for our sakes around
enjoyment
[__] see that yeah and the funny
thing is they even like they even gave
us like an SSR catch because there was
one golden fish there was one there was
there was in the sea of like gray fish
there was one golden fish that they put
in the bucket which was the SSR cap yeah
that was Five Points yeah which is five
points and so so um we decided to do fly
fishing in uh Lake Tahoe or near Lake
Tahoe and I was like I've done fishing
before how hard could this be you know
I've I've had I've had some fishing
experience uh I didn't so it kind of
confused me when we decided to do fly
fishing that there was like an hour-long
kind of like tutorial stage I was like
what are we doing for an hour do you
want to explain fly fishing for people
who don't know what it is I still don't
know what the technical definition is of
fly fishing but if you've ever seen in a
movie or a TV show where someone's
fishing and they're doing this a lot
it like spins or does like something to
catch the the attention of the fish
right uh that's actually not so the
reason the reason something else maybe
because uh basically what I always
thought was uh fly fishing is the one
where you see people just like whipping
the line around before they throw it in
and that's because that's basically to
give you control over exactly where you
through where you throw the law in right
so you can control the the reason I've
realized why we needed an hour
um an hour long kind of like session
teaching us how to properly throw the
law is because it is actually quite hard
to keep control of uh your key control
of the length the exact length and the
direction uh and making sure because if
you throw it you need to throw it so
it's like the law uh and the line is
completely straight right which is a lot
and so you have to get like the timing
exactly right when you're kind of like
whipping it like back and forth back and
forth you let a little bit more go and
then depending on how much of the line
you let go which is the length of the
line you're trying to throw the timing
is a bit different because it's almost
like if you miss time it then the uh the
QuickTime event yeah it is it is it is
exactly a quick Time Event and you have
to go through this before even getting
your line into the river right right if
you [__] it up then you've already
you've like you've already [__] up
basically because there's you know
there's so many things that can go wrong
maybe whip it too hard and then the line
goes into the water before you actually
throw the line in because you're meant
to throw it in as softly as possible so
let's mentioned just like kind of like
um it's kind of like meant to be like a
leaf or something or like like an insect
just dropping off and just like falling
to the river but if you like [__]
whip it in the water that's obviously
going to scare this scare the fish right
um so it's uh this is like fishing with
the uh Dark Souls patch like put in
there's a lot more it sounds like a
multi-faced boss fight yeah it is it is
a multi-phase boss fight because on top
of that uh all the fishing I'm used to
is that when the line's in you just wait
right you don't have to do anything and
you wait for the pool yeah and we're fly
fishing
uh the hook that we're given was like
way smaller than what it usually is uh
so you have to like Eagle Eye your Eagle
Eye like the line on the water and as
soon as you see any kind of movement at
all you gotta [__] you just gotta
[__] pull up right you you actually
have to like you actually have to like
be attentive because uh how we how it
was explained to us is like the trouts
obviously they don't want to waste
calories eating something right so
they're not gonna like swim up and like
bite it what's gonna happen is you're
gonna drop the line they're gonna see
something that looks a bit nice and
they're gonna waste the least amount of
calories as possible we're just giving
it a nibble and they're just gonna let
go because again why are the trust so
concerned about calories like what are
they what are they bulking like okay
well well it's the survival right yeah
if they expend more calories to eat
something than it is then the calories
that they're eating right and then then
then they're gonna die yeah
gonna die okay yeah yeah so basically
you you have like a 0.5 second chance so
as soon as you see something you just
gotta [__] just yeah you have to it's
it is like it is like that fishing
minigame where you you you think you see
you think you feel something and as soon
as you think you feel or see something
you just gotta like press up you just
you just gotta press a yeah and ninety
percent of the time you uh you didn't
feel anything or you didn't see anything
it was just the movement of the water
and then on top of that which is
actually the part of that this is the
part that I like the most right because
fly fishing uh you don't reel it in
right you pull it in okay so you so
because the hook is a lot smaller than a
lot of other uh fishing I'm used to
um there's a chance that the trout could
just get away yeah and the trout could
uh actually free himself uh so you you
you do the yank to actually like set the
hook into the drought yeah yeah
um so that's that's why you have to yank
it really hard and once it's set
you gotta fight it right so you you
that's that's actually you you have to
you stamina ball pop song
the stamina ball pops up right the
stamina
the stamina bar pops up and what happens
is uh so there's there's different
things you have to do right so you
stagger the fish
you basically have to stagger the fish
you have to wear it down so you don't
okay so here's the thing
so you have to like angle Your Rod so
it's like the perfect angle where it's
like just a little bit bent right so
it's kind of like that so you so it's it
gives like resistance towards the fish
so if they're swimming like away you
have to angle it so it's not too like so
it's not too angry otherwise the line's
gonna snap but that's not too many it's
like it's a [__] Speed Run it's like
so this is the angle perfect movement
right here explained to us it needs to
be angle perfect so if they're swimming
away you need to angle it so it's the
perfect amount of resistance so they are
still like spending energy but not
enough that the line snaps but what
happens if the fish swims towards you
well that's when you actually start
reeling it in and you reel it in by hand
you start ringing it by hand so it's
kind of like it is literally the stamina
bar and you have to like angle your
controller so so that it's like perfect
it's the perfect angle it is it I guess
it's rooted in real life yeah it is
actually vents now it is actually rooted
if you would hope the people who make
these fishing games know how to fish
yeah sure there's somebody on the team
yeah
and uh I gotta say it is [__]
addictive holy [__] yeah I think my
little brother does it all the time yeah
I think he's like hooked on it yeah I I
think I I did it once and it's it's got
like the perfect gameplay Loop of just
like one more time just
uh with this one we uh we we have to put
them back because uh otherwise you uh
normally we we are under supervision
normally you need a fishing license and
uh you have them can only uh fish a
certain amount so you don't overfish the
lake or whatever so this one we're under
supervision so we didn't need a fishing
license and we put all the trouts back
um but yeah it was it was [__] I think I
get fishing now like after that after
like the Japan trip I was like this is a
this is pretty boring you know uh with
the fish just come to you and you're
like okay eating them isn't fun as well
yeah eating them is fun oh yes the cycle
of life but yeah fly fishing is the
fishing minigame uh for gamers it is for
gamers it is addicting and it's most of
the time it's like you get an hour of
just boredom of just like throwing it in
and then like the adrenaline rush of
like when you're actually fighting the
fish and like making like making sure
like I made this fish my [__] man I
showed him who's boss he knows you know
knows and then you catch it and you're
like all right that was that was
actually that was right that was that
was [__] hype actually I think of all
the fishing I've done which is two
um ice fishing was my least favorite oh
what's ice fishing like I mean I've done
that too it's just not fun I mean how
much did you catch I caught like seven
but what were the size of the fish you
were catching like that big yeah they're
like this yeah they're tiny I mean
there's no fish I know I know larger
that could survive though it's like the
most if if that's like the accurate mini
game yeah ice fishing is the like Cookie
Clicker yeah it is it's the idol fishing
it's like you don't really do much you
just I might want to keep tapping it and
although these old men were trolling me
uh and they they were they were trying
to make me as cold as possible because
they knew I was unprepared and they were
[__] with me but they also I'm
completely unrelated they kept calling
each other skip it skip it yeah by
Perfect yeah they're calling each other
hey this guy's a pervert I'm like I'm in
the same yeah I'm uncomfortable
um yeah but that was just like
and then you'd catch something you're
like oh great the world's smallest fish
I mean I thought it was really fun
because I did it on journey across Japan
I thought it was super fun because you
guys all had your own like nice private
room yeah we were in like a tent
together and like it was Pete and Chris
versus me and nasty and it was only fun
because we [__] destroyed Pete and
Chris yeah we're literally sitting right
next to us like this distance apart own
hole to fish through and we were just
fishing all this I could see that I
could see the joy in it if you were in a
nice tent and you had like a heater yeah
you had some beers yeah and just
chilling with the boys yeah yeah I get
it but as like uh the actual fishing
aspect I was just like it's nice so
boring yeah yeah for sure it's like
there's I realize different types of
fishing are good for different types of
let's say environments I've been ocean
fishing as well I [__] despise those
[__] that was actually actually ocean
fishing was the worst one yeah ocean
fishing was like the combination of ever
like all like the most boring parts of
fishing with just an unpleasant
experience yeah I've only I've never
done it I've only seen like footage of
people doing it looks like hectic but in
the most not fun way yeah yeah yeah it's
just like you you're you're you the
adrenaline is rushing through your body
but you're not catching anything yeah
honestly fly fishing has been my
favorite so far uh in terms in terms of
just I I think I think I'm like next
time I get an opportunity I'm definitely
gonna try it again uh and uh [__]
diet has destroyed everyone it's the
Mainer in him I don't like like I caught
three fish uh on average like in our
group people call like two or three fish
cynical one uh dieters like caught nine
and then he stopped early because he was
like I think I'm done
I've maxed out yeah he stopped like half
now before everyone else did and then
there's me like half an hour after our
time has run out to be like come on just
one more I just want to throw one more
line it's this line This is the line
he's a kid who finishes the test 30
minutes yeah yeah right
now you're doing the exam and then
someone stands up 30 minutes in yeah two
hour exam you're like what's like this
[__]
okay fine write my name
that's always the thing
are they smartish [__] or are they dumb
as [__] I can't tell oh [__] yeah